you're listening to the real estate talk
show
with simon janini and erin mccoy on talk
radio
am 640. welcome back to the real estate
talk show your source for all things
real estate
now simon we know that for some real
estate is single-handedly the most
important investment in people's lives
while for others it can mean
big business to talk about all sides of
real estate investing with us today and
to learn more about all of his endeavors
is kevin o'leary so kevin thank you for
joining us via phone
thank you very much you must remember
what was your first
investment the one that stands out that
you remember my very first investment
was actually a home on shaw street in
toronto as my first real estate purchase
110 000 i had no money and i was able to
wrangle a mortgage i think i probably
put 20 000
down on it and of course as this story
is consistent with many people
others just like it it ended up being
one of the best investments i ever made
it was a time when real estate
every year was going up five to seven
percent of course i don't think we have
that anymore but
that's a wonderful experience and a
great memory now maybe you can tell us
about your take on the real estate
market today
i have multiple views on it real
estate's always 20 of my portfolio
and the way i vary the risk is the
quality
and the cap rates that i'm buying and
selling so today
i probably have my lowest exposure real
estate i've had in probably 20 years and
in canada
i have been divesting and my thesis is
cap rates are going to go up
we have close to historic lows on
premium office for example
my storage facilities i've sold all of
them you know those were things i was
buying in 11 cap
i was able to sell them at just under
six i just don't see a scenario cap
rates go down
anymore because rates in my opinion
between 2014 and 2017 are going to go up
at least 200 basis points so when that
happens you get a lot of headwind
going right into real estate whether
it's commercial whether it's residential
whether it's industrial
no matter what class it is it's fighting
an uphill battle for capital
appreciation
we get the question all the time how's
the market how's the market how's the
market
don't you also want to differentiate
when you're talking about different
locations in canada
or residential versus commercial how do
you see that playing out
i agree with you there's so many sub
segments in this market in real estate
investment
asset class but i'm trying to address
the overall
theme for the last 20 years and this
includes every asset class of real
estate in canada
we have had a decline in baseline
interest rates
and what has fueled this long fantastic
bull market in real estate has been
exactly that rates have gone
down from the 40-year average of 6.2
percent
to for a while under 2 and that's such a
massive percentage decrease but of
course you're going to get this
fantastic run-up in hard assets like
real estate
and my point now is it's the reverse
we're now going to go back
up to the mean over the next x number of
years back up to 6 on the 10-year
government bond
i don't think real estate's going to
appreciate materially in the next seven
years i don't think it's going to be the
best place to deploy capital
i don't care what sector i don't care if
it's offices in vancouver
condos in calgary or residential homes
in toronto
and i want to sound like a bear you
sound a little doomsday
just a little kevin i'm just saying it's
going to be flat i think you can buy
other assets that appreciate more with
the same risk
or less risk profile that's all i mean
you know i've got to call it like it is
and
as a result i have divested dramatically
in my real estate holdings in the last
two years yeah i know you're practicing
what you're preaching
but let's go south of the border i mean
we talked a little bit about canada here
but what is your thoughts in terms of
south of the border
whole different ball game okay whole
different ball game
you see what we didn't get in canada was
a massive correction in both
uh land itself we're all land yeah we
avoided that didn't we
we did and as a result the opportunity
now
has moved south of the border i think
you're going to get over the next five
years
probably on average somewhere between
five and seven percent appreciation and
pretty well every asset class in real
estate
in the us market it has been so
depressed for so long
you know we're down to five months of
inventory and new homes being built
land values and places like phoenix that
were decimated have flattened and
started to turn up
i'm not talking dramatic increases but
it's definitely
having gone to a massive correction a
much better place to deploy money
if i were a canadian looking to you know
maintain a 20
allocation to real estate in my
portfolio i would do it all in the u.s i
wouldn't do it in canada you're
listening to the real estate talk show
right here on am
640 and we're talking to none other than
kevin o'leary now kevin
we talked about florida and you know
some of the stats we're getting now we
talk about the us in general we look at
the hottest locations like florida or
phoenix
we're now seeing 30-day inventories you
know value increases of 10
15 and i agree i mean we're still
looking at
half of the construction costs that you
see in the u.s because they had a more
dramatic
decline in prices in some of those areas
and i agree i think they're going to be
coming back up even more dramatically
over the next few years
yeah i agree i mean i i and it's just a
result of the higher volatility in those
markets
miami is a remarkable situation from a
you know a really bad low 2000 2008
in some cases you've doubled your money
already but these are
premium locations particularly on
coastal properties
the inland lot on a golf course has not
had that kind of appreciation
i was just looking at some prices in
palm beach recently they're up sort of
15
from the bottom but you can find condos
in miami that have doubled so i mean
it's
very regional and it depends very much
on the property but the trend there is
up
it's not like canada where the trend is
flat to down the trend there is up and
i'm also concerned here in our canadian
markets when we talk condos
there's 86 000 units coming on the
market just in the toronto region the
next 30 months
that's a lot of inventory and i'm not
saying that these prices will decline
dramatically it's just that
that's another headwind in terms of
capital appreciation yeah you've got a
brace for everything that's coming
you're right you cannot stick your head
in the sand and there's hope for the
best
but you can also analyze different micro
markets yeah any final
tips or tactics for our listeners that
are considering maybe buying their first
investment
what would your recommendation be what
they used to do and what they should do
now are going to be two different things
and here's my advice
mostly when you you know let's say a
decade ago when you were buying your
first home
you'd go right to the max in terms of
what you could afford
and you might buy something that you
have to carry you know and probably
spend 40 percent of your income
supporting the mortgage
i would not do that i would say look if
i wanted to live in 2 000 square feet
be happy in 1500. underbuy is a safer
thing to do now so you're not levering
yourself up dramatically secondly
i would never buy a floating rate
mortgage today that would be very very
foolish
definitely fixed rate you can still get
great pricing sort of around depending
on your credit
three to four percent five year fixed
that is a phenomenal price
given historic rates you gotta live
somewhere so i understand exactly what
you're saying
but i would have a more tempted and
conservative approach going into it i
just don't think
in canada we're gonna get material
increases in the next five to seven
years in terms of the value of these
homes as you said everybody needs to
have a roof over their head
but i'm going to flip it a little bit
because i just left cottage country and
you're there right now in the comfort of
your home
so let's talk a little bit about cottage
country real estate it's not a necessity
it's uh
certainly not a need it's a want so
what's your thought on that
i don't think cottages are a good
investment to be honest with you
i mean i love my cottage don't get me
wrong but it is a negative
cash flow cost to me and so it's almost
an expense every year to maintain it and
cottages in muskoka
and around the region have not had any
capital appreciation
since you know the highs of 2007. so
what lots of people i know are doing
because they know this is an asset
you're only going to use for 60 to 90
days
they're finding the nicest cars on the
market to buy and offer to rent it
and so if you do the math you're better
off renting than you are buying and this
is from a guy that owns one
i look at the cottages that are for sale
around where i am
and some of them are you know
breathtaking prices
five six seven eight million dollars
there's been no trades at all in that
no range to very liquid asset class
you're asking is a fiduciary now as an
investor and
it is not a good thing to buy the taxes
are crazy in the cottage country in
ontario
for the services you get but this is
only putting my hat on as investor now
as someone who loves to sit on the dock
with my feet in the water no better
place
yeah but i'm just having this discussion
with my wife that she plans even
more renovations i'm saying to myself
this is insane this is an app that i
live in for six weeks that cost me more
than my home in boston or in toronto so
and i'm speaking to you as a rational
investor yeah no absolutely and we take
pride simon
and telling it like it is and certainly
we know that that's how you function but
i want to go into your book here i
actually finished reading your
kevin o'leary cold hard truth on men
women and money
your book covers a lot of just great
tips and a lot of what you've already
said but maybe you can touch more about
your book
i was very surprised about what happened
with men women and money because
i was not anticipating a book that sort
of examined
financial responsibility to be popular
it just shows you
how many people are concerned about
their futures when it comes to money we
talk about health
we teach our kids about geography and
math and we don't teach them anything
about money
so this has become one of my sort of
causes now and i'm working on my third
book in exactly the same
area financial literacy is so important
because
bad habits regarding money happen at a
very young age
it doesn't matter whether you're dealing
with someone who's very from a wealthy
family or middle class or poor
the same attributes are things that
should be taught to children because
each individual has to fend for
themselves in the long run and that's
really what this book is about is to
prepare
everybody from a seven-year-old right up
to when you're 60 retiring
on how to deal with it well hats off to
you because it's a great read so again
for all of our listeners out there
it's kevin o'leary's cold heart truth on
men women and money
and you know what you have so much else
going on but we're going to have you
back on the show so we can talk about
all the other ventures does that sound
okay
i love you guys i'm happy to do it
anytime and we love how you tell it like
it is
thank you great to have you on the show
we'll have to have you live in studio
maybe when the
when the weather changes winter time you
know when it's snowing i'll come to your
warm studio
very good take care bye-bye bye well we
do need to take a short break but when
we come back aaron and i will be
answering some audience questions around
real estate in the gta as well as a
cottage country we have time so you'll
want to stick around for that
and later on in the show we have peter
politis principal from graybrook capital
who'll be joining us here in the studio
to discuss
investing in real estate developments
now for those of you seeking the inside
track to all things real estate you can
join our insiders club and be kept up to
date with the latest news and investment
opportunities
and remember if you've got questions
we've got the answers all you have to do
is go to real estate talkshow.ca to join
the club and ask any real estate
question
or call our help desk anytime
90 416-366-9090 and you can also follow
us on twitter at real talk show
you are listening to the real estate
talk show right here on talk radio am
640 so stay with us